some of you guys might be a little too
young for it but yeah it's like one of
those things like mom you ever get that
not-so-fresh feeling and then she looks
and then this she's like running for
like a Kotex or a tampon
no one can create a viral video and
anyone that says to you that can make a
viral video it's going to be lighters
but you cannot reverse engineer a viral
video 72 hours of video uploaded to
YouTube every minute less than three
percent of videos upload to you to go
over 1,000 views hi my name is David wah
and I'm an entertainer living in Los
Angeles I've been given seven chances to
create a viral video this is my
adventure and I invite you to come on
with me can I go viral
can we tell you what took y'all want to
like Tara okay go there we go I was
awesome she's so naughty she's so
naughty yeah yeah oh it definitely can
be done um and it's like there's no kid
so there's no word can in a viral video
I think he's looking too deep into viral
videos I mean there's this majority the
hit of viral videos is something that
spontaneous that's just taken at a spur
of a moment I mean if you look at news
coverage or footage of like news
reporters they randomly like show
something that happens and then like or
people with their camera phones end up
getting millions and millions of views
and thinking about it like it like it's
like it's like a big a science project
you know it's not rocket science you
Jessica and the fire witness is less
than a minute so it's just basically you
putting something out there in a minute
and just basically easy they lie people
laugh you let people cry you're going to
tell your story you're gonna do makeup
you're gonna do how to a fitness
training video you know all that can be
done in a viral video I'm definitely
nervous about I mean what I think for me
is the subject matter where you know
like I guess the pressure of having a
good viral video and and and if you try
to do it with comedy you really want to
you want it to be funny you know what
you want people people you have 30
seconds to gain people's attention and I
think that's the thing for me it's just
basically just trying to make it funny
and just try to make people like keep
you know watching the set of the 30
seconds going on to a minute um without
be like you know what I'm gonna move to
something else so and I don't want to I
don't want to lose the competition I got
cats like I babies I mean that's my
competition I think I one definitely
personality um and hot topics something
that pretty much I think one is gay
people's interest is like what's hot
what is the hottest thing that's going
on or something that's in the new
something that's in music something
that's in TV it could even be like what
happened last night on a football game
or something
like that people have toddlers and
tiaras honey boo boo um love you honey
boo boo she's cool um and I just I it
could be honey boo boo it could be Drake
and Chris Brown fight you know that's
probably something great so do you think
you're funny i mean we think you're like
basically if i think i think i'm funny
you know we gotta leave we gotta leave
the but we gotta leave it to the public
and see if that if that's true i don't
know you know who have to see we'll have
to see based on how many how many how
many clicks I get you know on a YouTube
and how old were you the first time that
somebody said to you man you are funny
oh man uh that would probably be when uh
maybe in first grade or something like
that yeah I do well I don't I can't even
I think I actually it was in like church
um I ran for an award like one of those
summers ease commercial I'd like and a
church event um and that kind of got me
in trouble so yeah I think that was what
i do i I was just like in slow mo kind
of like running up and down the church
till I remove like every article of my
clothing all the way coming up to like
the pulpit and that was kind of like
that's a no no you can't be like
stripping yourself down into like your
underbred type thing so yeah that was
when I was like okay I think I'm like
yeah if we have to do some of them no I
got suspended I got suspend it was a
private school I got suspended yeah so
yeah I was I was in deep trouble for
doing something like that so yeah did
any of the kids like applaud you though
oh they all applauded me like I was like
oh everybody was rolling in their seats
but the principal and the teachers uh
did not find that funny so yeah I'm
receive summer's here yeah I don't know
some of you guys might be a little too
young for it but yeah it's like one of
those things like mom you ever get that
not-so-fresh feeling and then she looks
and then this she's like running for
like a Kotex or a tampon so it's like
yeah it's one of those girls were spine
the girls loved it I gross definitely
loved it yeah they loved it everybody
loved it as I'd like the teachers and
the principles I think probably wanted
to print like a principal and a teacher
public smirked on the side but they were
like we're gonna make an example out of
this kid
join me David war for the next episode
of can I go viral well I was soon
attempt to make a viral YouTube video